let's bring an update on a story that's
gathered a lot of attention this week
and this is the west ham player kurt
zuma who was filmed uh kicking and
hitting his pet cats and that footage
that was on social media which brought
the incident to light was filmed by his
younger brother johan zuma who is a
player
for the club dagnam and redbridge we've
just had a club statement uh regarding
euro and zuma it says uh joan was this
week contacted by the rspa rspca to
assist in their investigation and is
fully cooperating with them however
dagnam and redbridge would like to
reiterate that it condemns any form of
cruelty towards animals and fully
understands the reaction of many of its
supporters the club has therefore
decided that until the rspca has
completed its investigations johan will
not play for dagnam and redbridge in any
competitive match any further action
deemed necessary to be taken will be
made at the conclusion of the rspca
investigation so that is dagnam and
redbridge football club suspending
kurt zuma's younger brother from the
club for his part in that incident
involving the west ham players two pet
cats